somebody please
help
me betrayed by this
town let's tear it all down we all just
[Music]
a it all everyone's freaking
out the the libs you know the libs
anytime there's anything new they say oh
this is so exciting oh I love this new
thing even if it'll destroy ization
that's great and the conservatives you
know what the conservatives is going to
destroy the where the West has fallen
everything's gone to pot okay the
primary application for this stuff is
not going to be music it's not going to
be political news shows and commentary
and lectures and it's not going to be
any of that you know what it's going to
be the primary application for this
technology is going to be three words
weird sex stuff we all know it